let's see how we can preprocess our data
for masked language modeling
as a reminder mass language modeling is
when a model needs to fill the blanks in
a sentence
to do this you just need texts no labels
as this is a self-supervised problem
to apply this on your own data just make
sure you have all your texts covered in
one column of your data set
before we start randomly masking things
we'll need to somehow make all those
texts the same length to batch them
together
the first way to make all the texts the
same length is the one we use in text
classification
let's patch the short texts and truncate
the long ones
as we have seen when we preprocess the
data for text classification this is all
done by our tokenizer with the right
option for padding and location
this will however make us lose a lot of
text if the examples in our set are very
long
compared to the context lengths we
picked
here all the portion in grey is lost
this is why a second way to generate
sample of text with the same length is
to chunk or text in pieces of context
length instead of discarding everything
after the first chunk
there will probably be a remainder of
length smaller than the context size
which we can choose to keep and pad or
ignore
here is how we can apply this in
practice
by just adding the return overflowing
tokens option in order canizer call
note of this gives us a bigger data set
this second way of chunking is ideal if
all your texts are very long but it
won't work as nicely if you have a
variety of lengths in text
in this case the best option is to
concatenate all your tokenized texts in
one big stream with a special token to
indicate when you pass from one document
to the other
and only then splits the big stream into
chunks
here is how it can be done with code we
have one loop to concatenate all the
text and another one to chunk it
notice how it reduces the number of
samples in our data set here there must
have been quite a few short entries
once this is done the masking is the
easy part there is a data collector
designed specifically for this in the
transformers library
you can use it directly in the trainer
or when converting your data set to
tensorflow datasets before doing
keras.fit with the 2tf dataset method